how much of the Discord that we see in
the west at the moment do you think is
self-generated by polarization because
social media and Echo Chambers and blah
blah and how much do you think are seeds
that are sewn by Foreign actors China
and Russia and such like yeah so I I
mean I can confidently say from
experience that most of the noise that
we hear is internally generated the
whole idea that foreign actors create
narratives that cause Discord is proven
false in in many ways it's it's in case
studies it's in books that people just
don't read but it's also it violates the
core the core strategy and covert
influence isn't to create a new
narrative it's very hard to create a
narrative that anybody hears the the way
that you actually cause Discord or or so
miscontent is by just adding fuel to an
existing fire
so whether you're Russia or China or
Iran or whoever when you want to cause
conflict in the United States all you do
is add fuel to the existing fire there's
no lack of fires that people can add
issue to right whether it's the Snowden
debate or whether it's the Wikileaks
debate or whether it's gender or whether
it's woke or whether it's sex or whether
it's you know whatever I just found out
about something called incel recently
there's a thousand different things that
you can just pay a marketing company to
put a few extra ads out there that say
incel is the worst thing ever and women
should adhere to men and then you pay
the same marketing agency to send a
second message that says you know women
are equals and you know men who complain
about women are dogs and then boom all
you're doing is just pouring fire
pouring fuel on an existing fire
I had a conversation a couple of months
ago with a friend Gwenda Bogle and he's
got an idea around fire hosing that in
the Modern Age It's so difficult to
convince anybody of any particular one
narrative so the goal is to bombard
people with so many narratives that they
become despondent and nihilistic and
give up because at that point they are
the most easy to sway into one
particular you have two responses
basically it's the you know kick a dog
does the dog bite or does it give up
well either of those when you don't deal
with the biting that's that's fantastic
that's going to be looting and riots and
issues and whatnot and then the
despondency as well is going to make for
an easier country to roll over to yeah
it's interesting because the uh the
Strategic Benefit of it overall is still
kind of in the theoretical stages we've
never seen we've never seen in history a
country that's able to just roll over
another country by just devastating them
culturally like cultural subversion is a
a theory with lots of real world
evidence but no real world proof of of
of execution
right so I agree with you but then
there's also the element of the fact
that we just we're also all still as
much as we hate to admit it we're all
still adapting to a digital era we're
all still getting used to what it's like
to have smartphones and smart TVs and
you know you name it smart watches so
we're being we are choosing to get our
to let ourselves be bombarded with
information but we're also choosing what
information bombards us so yes we could
put out a thousand different narratives
but the algorithms in YouTube and social
media and whatever else are only going
to feed you the narratives that you
engage with the most so then you're
going to become the most engaged with
the narratives that you see the most
frequently which are the narratives that
you already believe in the most so
that's that's exactly the problem with
America it's that once you have once
you've told YouTube what kind of content
you like they don't give you any other
content they only give you what you like
once you tell Twitter what hashtags you
like that's what they keep feeding you
and everything want to suggest someone
you might like nobody ever suggests the
uh the counter point of view you know so
it it just drives this continued uh
wedge between everyone one of my friends
says that if you want to see into
somebody's soul and work out who they
truly are look at their YouTube
suggested videos
that and I don't think that it's too far
wrong the algorithm on YouTube is the
most accurate as far as I can see of
serving me content there is every time I
go on YouTube there is
five videos that I add to my watch later
playlist because I think oh that's
perfect and that's oh brilliant dude
World War II in numbers how Hitler
defeated the whatever whatever yeah
that's perfect for me and then there's
something about MMA and whatever
um
one of the things that I find is a kind
of an interesting uh contribution here
is that when we think about our
relationship to technology and the
difficulty that we have around marrying
all of this together I think not having
a common enemy causes us to have nothing
to band together about as well
especially when the enemy is internal
because the tribalism you see tribes
relatively all the time they're
splitting off fracturing this group was
against that group but now this part of
that first group is part of another part
of that same first group and
that seems to be a very good way to
waste the time of a country
in not making progress towards anything
meaningful culturally by constantly just
repeating similar cycles and fighting
against itself or just letting a country
distract itself right so I don't know if
you have kids I don't know if you've got
nieces or nephews or anything but
anybody with children knows that
sometimes the best way to give yourself
a break from the kids is to just let
them distract themselves just give them
if you give a six-year-old an iPad and
you tell them they can watch whatever
they want to on YouTube
they will distract themselves and you
won't hear from them for hours right if
you give them a if you give any kid in
under the age of nine if you give them a
bucket of toys even if it's just the
toys from the neighbor's house next door
if you give them a bucket of toys
they've never played with before they'll
distract themselves essentially that's
what that's all a country really has to
do is just give the tools to one country
to distract itself and in that process
they kind of uh they're they're free if
you're hearing background noise I'm in
DC so there's all these I mean it's like
helicopter Central you got the president
and the Congress people flying all over
the place all the time so it's just
helicopter City very nice I was in a
Long Island is that the one in New York
yes I was in Long Island uh start of the
year
I cannot believe the volume of planes
it's every 90 seconds pretty much 24
hours a day pretty much 365 days a year
yeah why the [__] do you live here what
and apparently it's really really nice
and it was beautiful and I enjoyed my
time there but
that's intense that is an intense flight
path so it's something else that I was
thinking about and I this really came up
to me when uh last year the 20th
anniversary of 9 11 uh and I'm a Brit
you know I was
12. I think and 9 11 happened
um
it hit home to me the way that it must
have had such an impact on the lives of
America
um with some of the documentaries that
were done you know some of the the video
footage that I'd never seen before some
of the testimony of the
um FDNY guys that had been going in and
I was on one side of a door and I got
down this set of stairs and my best
friend who I'd worked with for 20 years
was on the other side of the door and
he's not with us anymore I just so many
it was really really moving I thought it
was an amazing way to sort of show
tribute and and
re-educate people about what had
happened especially people perhaps that
hadn't even been around you know and
something that I found pretty
interesting is the modern confusion
around the word conspiracy every time
that somebody brings up the term
conspiracy online there is a whole bunch
of comments that'll say something like
well you know uh yesterday's conspiracy
is today's top news headline uh and it
does seem like the word conspiracy can
be used to discredit genuine stories
that powerful groups don't want to gain
steam it can be used to create stories
that misdirect people away from things
that genuinely are true
that just fascinated me thinking about
that especially looking back um last
year yeah I have a whole I mean I have a
YouTube video out there that teaches
people the anatomy of a conspiracy teach
us tell us well yeah there's there's a
lot that goes into it but there's
essentially just a few core ingredients
right so first there has to be something
that happens there there has to be some
factual event something that's that's
evidentiary something you can see you
can you can touch you can hear whatever
it might be has to be a kernel of Truth
somewhere yeah it's not that that's how
every con can uh everything has to start
with a kernel of Truth but then what
happens is immediately after that there
has to be a lack of information
so there has to be an element of truth
that's immediately followed by a lack of
information
now what happens cognitively is the
human brain wants closure the human
brain always wants to close every open
loop of reasoning so when you hear
something that's truthful right there's
an unidentified object in the sky
right then there's a gap of information
well what was it was it a plane we don't
know was it a helicopter we don't know
there's no information about what it was
now the human brain doesn't like that so
the human brain starts to seek
possibilities
so the third ingredient in a conspiracy
has to be a series of potential
explanations now in that series of
potential explanations here's what ends
up happening we forget we forget that
we're just going through a series of
potentialities and we start to think
instead that the potentialities are in
fact the explanation and then we start
to enforce the explanation that we
believe explains the original kernel of
truth that's how a conspiracy is born so
uh the the Twin Towers are destroyed in
911. two airplanes crash into them
that's there's all sorts of kernels of
Truth out there that let us know it's
real but then there's this break in
information how did the pilots get
training and when how did they organize
this whole thing and how did the police
not find out and how did CIA and FBI not
find out and and then even when there's
an explanation about how CIA and FBI
didn't communicate effectively
there's still lots of information that
people don't get we want to know what
intels were out there we want to know
what sources were out there but they
don't get that information
so then they start saying well why is
nobody sharing what could be in that
information oh it was an inside job they
don't want to admit that there was a
there was an element inside the US
government that wanted this to happen or
or there you know whatever else it was
the Israelis and they don't want to let
these you know they don't want to tell
anybody that's the Israeli so these
crazy I call them crazy but these
conclusions these these estimations pop
up in the in the absence of information
and then people are like if it was an
inside job they would have been able to
keep it secret because they control all
their own information right and then all
the if then start and the if thens on
their own are valid right if you wanted
to cover something up here's how you
would do it if it was if if it was the
Mormons that did it then this is how
they would cover it up whatever it is it
would all be in there so because this
reasoning is sound and this fact is
sound the conspiracy exists even though
nobody is accounting for the fact that
there's there's nothing connecting the
two sides that are reasoned and well
thought out and without something to
connect the two there's no foundation in
truth every single morning for over
three years now I've started my day the
exact same way which is with element in
water element contains a science-backed
electrolyte ratio of sodium potassium
and magnesium and it is the best
hydration drink that I've ever found it
tastes fantastic it's super refreshing
orange is just the most OP flavor in the
world it's absolutely phenomenal and it
helps to play a critical role in
reducing muscle cramps and fatigue it
regulates your appetite it optimizes
brain health and it helps curb Cravings
they're also the exclusive hydration
partner to Team USA weightlifting and
rely on by tons of Olympic athletes and
everyday High performers all around the
world also there is a no BS no questions
asked grief and policy where you can buy
a box completely risk-free and if you do
not like it for any reason they will
give you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you love it element of giving
away a free sample pack of all eight
flavors with your first box if you go to
the link in the description box below or
drink lmnt.com
MW that's drink
lmnt.com
MW what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe